foreign
[Silence]
authored by ibn kayim
islam
what is the topic of this book a person
may ask
what is the subject
of zadil ma'at
the subject of
is the prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
everything we know about him
or should i say everything that
ibn al-qaeda
knew about the prophet muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
anything that he said
anything that he did
anything that he
confirmed
and even things that don't have
anything to do with
our religious duties
such as
the way that he looked
the way that he spoke
right his voice
things that these things that are
natural things that every person is
different in
the prophet
salallahu anything having to do with him
ibn kayim documented it as best as he
could and harmonized it in this book
zadil
it is one of the most critical in my
opinion
most critical and most important books
in the islamic library
but
it is a complex book it is complicated
and that is why
in
i don't know 40 some classes or
something we've done so far
we've gone through
the first volume
how could we have gone through the first
volume and only those many classes
because obviously we're not reading
every single thing
because there's a lot of things a lot of
complexities and nuances that ibn okay
goes into
that
are more
appropriate for scholars and more
more sought-after
pieces of information with regards to
students of knowledge and scholars
than they are with the general people us
just regular people
the things that we need to learn the
gist of it is what we're focusing on
from
so obviously we are
summarizing
summarizing and paraphrasing
has mentioned so we could probably take
this
as an abridgement of z
and so
the last topic that we were speaking
about is the
chapter regarding the
things that a person can do to open his
heart
the things that a person can do to open
his heart
so
islam as we've mentioned before
is a religion
it is
as people put it often a way of life
but allah subhanahu wa ta'ala also
refers to al-islam
as a millah
and emilia is a way of life that is
all-encompassing
and intrusive
meaning that it has something to do or
something to say about everything a
person can do or say
even
things that allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
does not speak about
not speaking about something is
essentially saying something
what does that mean
the prophet
salallahu said
[Silence]
he says
indeed allah has
obligated things so do not
fail to fulfill those obligations
he has placed limitations so do not
cross the boundaries of allah
he has
made certain things haram
so do not
indulge in those impermissibilities
and he has also
remained silent about many other things
as a mercy for you all
not because he is unaware of them or
forgot to mention them
so do not ask about these things what
does this mean
this means that allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala silence on something
is
essentially ibaah
is essentially that it is permissible
right
so him
not
saying do this or don't do this
particular thing
rather leaving it to the discretion of
the person
this is what we called
we call it
we categorize it as muba neutral
and neutralities are to the discretion
of a person
that is a ruling isn't it
yes so emila is anything that has to do
with any action of the human being
anything everything the entire existence
for of the human being
from the moment he is able to comprehend
until the day that he dies
this is a miller
right
now
it is also a discipline
islam
is a discipline
a lot of people don't understand that
concept
a lot of people
look at the polar opposites
right
they see islam
and they see kofo
and there's nothing in between
and that's not correct that's not a way
that a person should view things
yes a person is either muslim or
non-muslim in the general sense we will
categorize there are certain conditions
for a person to be a muslim
right
if they fulfill these conditions they
are a muslim
but in order for a person to be a good
muslim
a dutiful muslim
a muslim on the path of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
there is a discipline
that goes along with it
what do i mean by a discipline
so for example let's say a person
becomes muslim
many of us
are born into islam
right many of the audience listening is
born into islam
our parents are muslim
but that doesn't mean that we are
automatically entered into paradise
we have to also consciously make a
decision to accept islam as well
is that not correct
yes by default we are muslim
but the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam tells us
that the person who is a hypocrite
a person who is
a fajr
person who is sinful
when he is placed into his grave
and the two angels come to ask him who
is your lord and what is your religion
who is your prophet he will stutter and
he will say
i heard people saying something so i
said what they said
this individual said
right this person may be fasted this
person but the problem is is that they
didn't make a conscious decision to
accept islam and make it into a
religious issue
they just did what everybody was doing
they did what the crowd was doing
this kind of person
if they were in a jewish community they
would have been
jewish
if they were in a christian community
they would have been christian if they
were in a buddhist
demographic they would have been
buddhist etc
for this reason a person has to reach a
point in his life where he realizes
islam
in his life
and so
many of us refer to that as the time of
istikham
yani a person is living his life
and
he has an epiphany
he has an awakening
a spiritual awakening as if allah has
tapped on his heart
okay
and he begins to pray now his prayer is
different
he feels that he is praying to allah
he begins to refrain from things
not because they are taboo in his
culture but because
in his heart
no matter where he would be
he would refrain from this thing and he
would do this thing
this awakening
okay that a person has
is essentially
a type of entrance into islam it doesn't
mean you weren't muslim before that it
just means that you were
a mukhalid in
what you were doing before that you were
just following the crowd
then when your mind awakens and your
heart awakens
now islam enters and it becomes a
personal thing
right
which many of us have experienced
correct
i mean the muslim world today is not a
very religious world at all
it's not
all over the world
the muslim world today what we consider
muslim majority countries
many people are not religious
we have things that we do we have things
that we don't do
we have bakayam and
[Arabic recitation]
okay
but it's not something that we really
think about
it's not an active discipline that we
have
that before i speak i think about what
i'm going to say and the ramifications
of this statement and if it's halal or
if it's haram and what will allah react
to this statement we don't have this
kind of
thought process right
it's just going with the flow
so
when a person has that religious
awakening
that have that spiritual awakening
that is a seed that has been planted by
allah subhana wa ta'ala
person now begins
to obey allah
not because of where he is or who he is
but he begins to obey allah because of
what he knows
and he begins to disobey shaytaan
because of what he knows correct
but
let's say before that a person was a
habitual liar they lie all the time
right
well now they have to stop lying they
didn't magically stop lying because they
became muslim
or they didn't magically stop lying
before because they started praying all
of the sudden
and so
they start to build up the discipline to
stop lying you understand
refrain from certain vices
they start to build up the discipline to
make sale on time
they start to build up the discipline of
focusing in prayer
right
i mean
and many of us had that discipline but
then after our fever and our fervor goes
away it starts to what
starts to drop
and this is why the scholars of sunnah
they mention
that
iman is belief in the heart
statement of the tongue
it manifests itself on the in the
actions of a person
it increases with good deeds and
decreases with bad deeds
right
and this is why the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam warned us so much of the
gray areas of islam
[Silence]
you
so
it's important for us to understand how
a person begins to turn evil after they
became muslim
okay i'm talking about this to scare
everybody i want you to be scared
i'm scared
okay
and as al-hasan al-basri rahimahullah
and this
turning evil after you become muslim
what do we call what is this referred to
in the in in this in the quran
what is it
we're talking about becoming evil but
you're still muslim
that is what it is
it is referred to in the quran as what
and it is referred to in the quran as
and sometimes allah mentions them
together
[Silence]
m
is
[Silence]
and so
what is this state of being when a
person is muslim but turns evil
they still have the pillars of islam
they still have the pillars of faith
okay but their faith becomes very weak
you understand
their islam becomes very weak
so they start to do evil major sins
right
they start to hurt people kill people
whatever do anything all of the terrible
things take riba okay
the dabble in seher
okay
a
all of these things
lie
cheat
scam
but they pray they make all the five
prayers they go to hajj they do all the
have we met people this before or
not
yet we all have right
these are people who are referred to in
the quran as people will have an illness
in their hearts
and sometimes they are referred to as
there's a narration where the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam says in sahih
muslim
he says
four traits
whoever has one of them
has a trait of nifak until he leaves it
off
and whoever has all of them is a munafir
a true hypocrite
even if he prays and fasts and claims
that he's a muslim then he mentions
those traits what are those traits
he says if he speaks he lies if he
is entrusted he is treacherous if he
makes a treaty he is treacherous if
he
promises he breaks his promise okay
these are four traits
does this mean that this person is no
longer a muslim if they have these four
traits
that's not what that means this means
that this person has
gone evil after he has become muslim but
he is still a muslim
and if he died upon that
having believed in allah in the last day
and not had any major shirk he would
enter paradise eventually
do you understand
this is why we say there is major nefar
and minor nifak right major hypocrisy a
minor hypocrisy
major volume and minor volume
is everybody with me
does anybody not understand what i'm
saying so far
very important information here
because
we get on a one-track mind here's how a
shaytan sets you up for failure you want
to hear how
i'm gonna tell you how
one of his tricks
okay
is that when you have that spiritual
awakening
and you start to pray
or if a person was a non-muslim enters
into islam
and you start to pray and fast and do
everything
a shaitaan will come to you
and convince you that
you're muslim now everything is going to
be okay
you understand
no that is not the promise of islam
in that totalitarian sense
okay
in christianity believe in whatever it
is that whatever the denomination wants
and you'll enter paradise that's it you
either go to hell or you go to
heaven that's it
right every religion promises that
except islam islam you can become muslim
and still go to hell it can still happen
right because islam is a discipline
so shaytan sets you up for failure
by telling you you're muslim now you're
good you're fine right and slowly evil
creeps into your heart
and when you look back after 10 15 20
years
we know this verse
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
and do not be those who were given
the book before you all
and a long time passed and
a long time transpired while they had
the book and they began slowly to lose
its teachings
until their hearts became hard
and many of them are truly rebellious
sinful individuals okay
so
a person can become evil even after they
have become muslim why
because the teachings of islam are a
discipline
okay
a person
says he does not lie you have to
practice that
that in the moments when it's most
beneficial to you to lie you tell the
truth
you always tell the truth
you when it's time to pray you always
pray that's it this is not
non-negotiable okay
but if you start to bend the rules
okay
if you start to blur the lines is this a
white lie or a black lie right
is is the salah time in or out
wait till the last second for salah
right and then make it
now evil is starting to creep into your
heart
because the prophet salallahu alaihi
this process
may allah help us all
he said
that which is permissible is clear
and that which is haram is clear
and between the two are gray areas that
most people don't know
most people who are the people that know
who are the people that know
man
[Silence]
which is clear to everyone and then
there is a gray area in between that
most people don't know whether it is
these are referred to as the doubtful
things things that are doubtful they're
sketchy okay
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said
whoever stays clear of these sketchy
things
then this person has preserved his honor
and he has preserved his religion
and whoever starts to indulge in these
sketchy things
than a person has
indulged in haram what does that mean
meaning you are going to enter into
haram eventually that's how shaytlan
trains you
he trains you first with
get a little closer a little closer a
little closer and then the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam gave an
example
he said just a shepherd
around a guarded land or a sanctioned
land
keeps getting closer and closer to the
perimeters of that land
it is very
at any moment he could actually be in
that sanctioned land
what does that mean well most of us we
don't shepherd
sheep okay so let's try to bring this
home and understand what the prophet is
telling us
what he's telling us is
let's say there is a piece of land where
the grasses seems really green and nice
okay
but that land is preserved it's it's
nobody is allowed to
enter into that land with their
livestock to eat from that grass
it's preserved but it doesn't have a
clear fence on it
okay
so what happens
a person needs to stay far away with his
flock of sheep
from that land
just as allah told adam
and do not come close to the tree stay
far away
okay
but what ends up happening is
the shepherd allows his sheep to wander
closer and closer and closer to the
sanctioned land and there's no fence
you know so we're not sure where it
starts and where it ends
right
and we come closer and closer and closer
until finally what happens
one of the sheep is now in the land
now two of the sheep are in the land
but who's to say they're really in the
land but anyways what's the difference
between this land and that land i mean
it's just you know it's all the same
before he knows it his entire flock is
inside of the middle of this sanctioned
land
this is what's going to happen
right
that's how a shaitaan trains a person
into haram
nobody said it's haram i'm not sure it's
haram so i'll do it i have something in
the back of my mind saying this might be
haram but don't ask don't tell
right
keep going keep going keep going until
what happens i'm doing minor sins now
i'm doing them all the time i'm doing
them constantly i'm doing them
habitually
now i'm doing major sins
and at first i'm upset about it but now
i'm doing it all the time now it's
become commonplace
and then a shaytlan comes to you after
all this and says
carlos what's the point now i mean he
already screwed everything up just keep
going
right
you already messed up
you already did the major sins
you've already gone too far
keep going
right
and so
these little tiny fires that were
happening now turn into a giant blaze
that burn you alive
right
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he said
in a narration
which is in muslim
he said minor sins
are an individual who goes into a
valley
and starts to gather firewood
right
so a stick from here and a little twig
here and a little stick here no small
log here
until it becomes a giant pile
and he ignites it and it burns him alive
this is what he said about minor sins
so
the same thing happens with money right
isn't the same thing happen with money
that's how they
nickel and dime us to death in this
country all right
it's just a five dollar subscription
it's just a ten dollar subscription it's
just thirty dollars a month it's just
three dollars it's just five dollars you
walk up to the checkout lane the
chocolate is only a dollar fifty it's
only the before you know it
you're you're paying more than you are
making now you're in debt
right
so you get in debt and you start using
something that is definitely haram to
try to get out of debt
so now you're using credit cards and now
you're paying reba now you're doing all
this stuff before you know it you're too
far in you might as well just give in
and just
go all the way
and this is how things work
the point here that we are making is
that a person can become muslim
and can be religious
but his religion
may
waver at a point
a person's religion may start to
deplete
a person's
discipline will start to go away
right
and so a person will yes be muslim but
he is an evil person
right
he's a person who is evil
he's not totally evil because no muslim
no believer is totally evil
but he's pretty close
right this is how this happens
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was asked
in the narration of
a muslim
listen to this narration
he was asked
the sins that we committed before we
became muslim
are they erased by us becoming muslims
[Silence]
is
in this narration the companions came
and they asked the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam o messenger of allah
the sins that we committed before islam
are they forgiven for us are they
forgiven
by us entering into islam
what did he say sallallahu
meaning before islam they killed people
they murdered people they committed zina
they did all these atrocities right they
did all of these things that are haram
are these things counted against us
after we've become muslim
he said sallallahu alaihi wasallam
whoever enters into islam
and continues to be good in islam
his previous sins will be forgiven
but whoever enters into islam and
becomes evil
after entering islam
he will be held to account for
what passed of his sins and what is to
come of his sins
what does that mean
let's say a person before islam
used to drink alcohol
okay
they become muslim
and they continue to drink alcohol
that means that
isla all the other sins that they did or
they are forgiven for
but the fact that they're continuing to
drink alcohol
means that
they are not sorry and not repentant for
the pastimes that they drank alcohol
so the time before they became muslim
they are held to account for
do you understand that concept
and so there is a chance and there is a
concept of a person who can become evil
as a muslim
we need to know that
you know why
because you need to be scared
as al-hasan al-basri rahimahullah he
said
and if
[Silence]
hypocrisy
is something that
no one
except a believer will truly fear
and a hypocrite is the one who will not
fear hypocrisy
none
what does that mean that means that if
you're fine and you're no i'm good
i'm safe now i'm this i'm that
be afraid of being a hypocrite of having
elements of hypocrisy
the true believer is always scared that
he will be amongst the hypocrites
we know the narration of umar with
hadith
correct
didn't
know the names of the 12
hypocrites in medina before the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam passed away
came to
and he said i ask you by allah was i one
of them did he name me as one of them to
you
who is this
but we go and we kick back and we say
it's going to work out
no you should be scared you should be
very scared of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
but not so scared that you're not
hopeful anymore
you need to be scared and you need you
need to be hopeful
scared of your sins
hopeful in allah's mercy that's the
beautiful
harmony that is going to lift you to
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
right
so
i'll end with a narration that will kind
of bring this all together
remember last week we said we have our
prime colors right
we have islam and we have
kofur we have tauhid and we have shirk
right
we have night and we have day we have
black and we have white but then we have
people that are in the middle
right
there are people that are careful but
they're not as bad
as as other kuffar and there are people
that are muslim but they're not as good
as other
muslims correct
for example we could take a perfect
example from the four uncles of the
prophet muhammad
how many uncles did he have
how many
say it say it quick how many did he
have
four
four uncles right let's name them yellow
number one
hamza number two
abu lahab number three
abu talib number four
la best that's where everybody opens his
mouth hello
two of them were believers and two of
them were kuffar correct
who were the two kuffar
abu lahab and abu
talib
but whose kuffar is worse
and whose kuffar is least
abu talib correct
we have al abbas and hamza
whose islam was best
and whose islam was
was not as as strong and as
fervent
as hamza
al-abbas
both of them are muslim both of them are
in paradise
the other two both of them are kuffar
both of them are in hell but they're not
in the same level
do you understand
and this is why we need to look at the
world as not every a non-muslim is a
combatant against islam
there are neutral types of non-muslims
so
here is a narration that will kind of
solidify this
[Silence]
foreign